hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for it's the
candidates tournament 2020 and we're
starting off with what I believe is the
best game of round one initiative versus
Yanni paunchy and it's it's the best
game around one because it's well it's
just extremely well prepared it's
extremely complicated and it's well it
it should be it should be in books you
know the positions that arise in the
game but we're gonna get back to that
what I've prepared for you also is a
nice photo of the opening ceremony of
the 2020 candidates tournament so here
as you can see I've seen this on Twitter
Leach has published it it's the well it
doesn't seem like they're interested in
the whole no large gatherings idea and
first I thought it was a joke but there
we have it freely present our cutted
work which next to Anatoly Karpov and I
believe the woman in red in the front
row is wholly fun I could be wrong
though but yeah very interesting I
didn't I didn't think there'd be such a
large gathering there
Alberto came it does say that everyone
present there is being tested twice a
day I don't know about all of them I
know that you know the players are there
seconds are and I well could be that
they are all being taste tested twice a
day but yeah just thought you'd enjoy
that and also here we have a nice photo
of nipple here we have it where with his
mask ready to join his teammates at the
link way you know but instead of instead
of the old get over here he it's more
likely gonna be a stay over there and
also here is a nice photo
I will not afford basically as their
previous head-to-head score as you can
see in classical games and Yuri Beatty
on Epona she's 3 to 2 with two draws so
definitely in favor for Anish but
including rapid and exhibition games
Gianni polish a bit uneasy in 9 to 5
with 9 draw so if we go into faster time
formats then Napo has the upper hand and
also before we check out the game the
first move was made by none other than
former world champion and little carp of
dairy habit so all that being said let's
check out the game
Giri opens with Knight to f3
we have sorry about that we have the
ready on the board we have Knight to f6
pineapple and c4
we have c5 so basically transposing into
the English Knight c3 and the Knight to
c6 the four Knights of the English we
have B for C captures on d4 Knight
captures on d4 and now II 6 just
continuing development with g3 and now
Bishop to c5 was the go-to move for
example I believe in 2019 but in 2020
Queen to b6 seems to be the main idea
for black oh okay we have nice beat the
b5 going for that to d6 Square and now
comes Knight to e5 not of course
allowing Knight to d6 check so like the
e5 now both the Queen and the bishop are
controlling the d6 square and now Bishop
to f4 so this has all been played before
nothing new and now Knight F the g4 here
Napo is threatening to capture on f2 and
of course if you play some like Bishop
captures then of course Queen captures
an f2 is the idea so III preventing that
and now a6 asking the knight to kindly
leave the outpost but of course before
doing that Giri plays h3 and these are
all tested ideas we have a character son
b 5h cap % g4 and Knight characters and
c4 so net points up a pawn but it's a
double beep on hard to say if it will be
if it will be good or not and this is a
non theoretical position queen the
position has been reached 12 times in
top two your games and Queen to b3
I was always played here in every of
those games but here you're prepared
rook the c1 so look the c1 is a new move
and this is what Gary prepared for
nipple to deal with in the first round
of the candidates tournament so it is as
I move 12 did we have a completely new
game so a default has to be played at
some point and well there's no point in
going Queen to b3 d5 and now there's no
point in going Queen to b3 as a d5
nicely guards the Queen so instead of
rook to c1 you could have gone Queen to
b3 because then okay you have a double
attack on this pawn here and if the
Queen was on be three you could capture
on c4 there was the threat of well if
pawn captures then the Queen on b6 is
undefended
but here b3 by Gary
attacking the knight and here nipa went
into a deep thing so this is all well
within Gary's preparation but it's very
unlikely that it is within any pony
she's preparation as Gary did most
likely surprising with that rook to c1
and as never really started burning his
time well probably probably had to find
everything over the board so here
basically what you're deciding you don't
want to move the knight if you move the
knight eg you're just giving back the
ponen for example if 96 bishop can
capture it let's say Bishop captures and
then you capture a bishop characters on
b5 with check so that that is possible
although if you have something better
you should play something better for
example 'if I've is a very interesting
idea I just going for that Bishop and
now after be captures and c4 you can
capture on f4 and now not allowing black
to fix this pawn structure you can go c5
Bishop captures on c5 and now Bishop
captures and B if I would check where
King would have to go to f8 if you don't
want to lose castling privileges but
then G characters on f4 and it doesn't
seem like White's doing all that bad
black still has to figure out how to get
the rook into the game and but but again
you are running into Girish preparation
so he might have considered this so
instead of this if i move i never place
these strongest move recommended by the
engine and that's Bishop to b4 so he
sacrifices a piece maybe temporarily
maybe not it's hard to say there are a
lot of complications here Gary basically
captured it instantly there was this
talk of the mood g5 but the g5 is such a
such an artificial move to make in a
position like this that it's it would be
it would be wrong to even talk about it
if if this wasn't such an important game
like the candidates tournament but the
point of g5 is that after E 5 comes now
the bishop is under attack now you play
Bishop captures on c4 and now after it
captures an f4 you go Bishop captures on
d5 and after F captures and g3 now you
go even King to f1 and if G captures an
f2 now you play queen d3 and you've
allowed all of this okay you want pin
that you allow the de-spawn to come to
f2 but now when you look at it
it's actually blacking who's in the
center of the board you cannot castle
because of Queen to h7 checkmate really
really hard to do for a human over the
board I believe impossible to evaluate
but okay that's that's why I said the
only reason I mention it it's because
it's the candidates tournament but okay
a giri instantly played beat captures
and c4 I'm sure Geary is aware of the g5
move but he decided that for practical
purposes not really something worth
gambling on for such an important game
so he immediately played B captures on
c4 and now neppo is down a piece but he
has a night here pin so he continues
attacking it rook the c3 a roof day
three threatening to pick up the knight
on c3 Bishop to e5 a very important move
guarding the night and now it seems like
black can trap the bishop with f6 and e5
problem is after f6 which was played in
the game nipple has a surgery has Bishop
to d4 which comes with an attack on the
Queen so you don't have time for a five
but now Queen to a5 adding a third
attacker here and now the problem is you
cannot defend it three times for example
if Queen to c2 then e five is extremely
strong and now you have to go into this
rook characters characters and
characters and only now he captures on
d4 and now for example Queen g8 check
pink the b7 e captors and d4 you could
try something like this a bunch of
characters and c3 but now after King - E
- pretty much everything falls apart
yeah you could drop in a few checks but
it's not gonna be a problem the King can
always hide on the Queen side and you
are just down a piece so of course
completely winning for black so after
this Queen to a5 Moogie retry did Bishop
to e2 he has to make a room for the King
on e on f1 Bishop captures on c3 with
check and now here's the problem if you
go Bishop characters on c3
rook captures rook characters and Queen
captures in c3 with check of course King
f1 and now be captures on c4 you've
under both your points you've created an
incredibly strong pass to be a pasty
pawn B 5 B 4 is coming and this looks to
be more or less winning for black so
instead we have rook captures on c3 and
again you replayed all of this
incredibly fast saying that
probably he's still well within his
preparation with rook captures on c3 and
now King to f1 unpinning so giri
sacrifices the exchange and now
well now it's an effort to make the move
and here the strongest move the
strongest move by the engine is B
captures in c4 and this is most likely
what giri was planning on the data
nipple we'll play this move and then he
probably had something ready for example
if you capture that then okay you again
created this incredibly strong fast pawn
but now g5 and it seems like white is on
the attack for example if castles then
Queen to be one can be very strong again
putting pressure here but black can
easily defend so not quite quite the
greatest of plans as for example f5 the
defense mate and it's it's not a problem
so after this g5 move you would have to
you would have to figure out something
else it doesn't really work here so
after B captures on c4 you would most
likely have to try something else either
either go for the rook or or maybe gear
we had this g5 move planned and he had
all the calculations you know already up
his sleeve but the problem is after some
10 minutes of thinking 10 minutes of
thinking b4 was played by nip oh and
here he didn't grab here he just pulled
the pawn here saying okay if you capture
the rook now I will give you back the
exchange but then I already have a
passed pawn on c3 and now Gary went into
a thing and this is the first time Gary
went I believe was a 10 minute thing the
first time you went into a thing since
the game started and well point is if
captures captures it's just an
incredibly strong pawn and c3 like but
you could go Bishop d7 to a4
kick away the Queen get the pawn all the
way to c2 seems like seems like an
incredibly strong form so instead after
this b4 move Gary continues in the same
fashion as if in a poke captured and
uncie for he continues with this g5 idea
he wants to bust open the position and
attack the black king and here it's
again nipple to make a choice and the
choice is basically between 'if I've are
kicking away the bishop
were capturing an a to capturing an a to
is incredibly interesting because if
capture is on a to then you get the G
captures and f6 captures Bishop captures
and now if Bishop captures then it's not
good for white for example rook to f8
and you will have incredible pressure
here on the f2 square due to the Queen
and the rook nicely combined like this
for example now with virtual characters
and c3b captures and you cannot move the
bishop due to due to checkmate and well
c2 is again coming it's gonna be very
very unpleasant what you could do is
after this G captures an f6 idea play
King to g2 but this is all very very
incredible stuff to find and now after
Queen to c2 offering a queen trade now
Bishop captures on f6 Queen captures and
d1 Bishop captures or even the route
capture sandy one and now for example
castles you attack the Bishop Bishop
captures pawn captures and now rook the
c1 so now you will win back your pawn
and it seems like this should be
playable so but a lot of things defined
after this g5 move by Gary so capturing
an a2 is basically trading down into a
draw but instead a nipple goes for a 5
he likes his position he wants to keep
the tension so now he basically forces
Bishop captures and c3 which is what
Gary does with Bishop characters pawn
captures and now G captures and f6 net
will recaptures and now that we have
Queen to be 1c captures and d5 also
seems like a reasonable idea but you
know it's it's Gary seems really
reluctant to waste a temple here
grabbing the pawn so instead he goes for
Queen to be one and it the queen is very
active here the Queen controls the h7
squares so rook captures and h7 might
already be an idea
black could have problems developing the
bishop due to Queen captures and b7 so
it's an it's an incredibly strong move
and again creates more complications so
neppo immediately brings back the Queen
Queen c7 just guards this and also that
twice so what's happening here regarding
the clocks it's 58 minutes giri and 48
minutes nipple and only a few minutes
ago gary was over an hour and a half and
a nipple was really struggling so here
Giri is out of the you know safe waters
of preparation and he also now has the
burn time so again what's what's
happening here after Queen to see seven
here let's see see character son b5 c2
is very strong so also the Queen from c7
does a great job of doing everything for
example queen c1 now comes the Bishop to
f5 just controlling that pawn ideas like
a queen here fall by Queen B one are
possible it's gonna be it's going to be
very unpleasant and on the other hand
after this Queen to c7 idea you could
try something like rook to h4 it's it's
very useful because it reinforces c4
prevents d4 and it's just a much more
active piece than than having it on h1
for example if d captures and c4 you
just capture here and next move you're
gonna capture the c3 pawn as well
because after Bishop takes to reach our
King g1 and black doesn't have a decent
continuation here so after Queen to c7
Gary didn't go for any of these ideas
the C capture so look here he played
Queen to d3 and here he'll out something
something more than he should have to
nipple so feel free to find this
mysterious move while I give you a
couple of seconds and also while I have
a nice it for my water so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations as it is it's really is
sticking out to that move ahead and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's B 5 and B 5 creates a lot of
problems here point is if if you do
something let's say capture on b5 then
c2 is incredibly strong and it's there's
not a lot you can do against this you
could just give up the exchange of
course with King to g2 and then just
bring the Queen into the game broke
characters and Queen recaptures but
that's just trading down into a losing
game game so now we would go into a
forced Bishop h5 check King g7 Queen to
a3 check Queen to b6 Queen to e7 check
blocks with the bishop and the now you
have to guard c1 so King to g2 but now
comes the
for and this is this is just beautiful
stuff it captures pawn captures and now
if you allow d3 and d2 it's a game over
so let's say rook to e1 with check King
to f8 and then outcomes Quinte to check
but after you move the King it is it is
impossible to stop to stop the pawns
so it's although it might be you might
be able to hold with perfect play not
something you want to even try
so instead capturing here it's the same
idea you just push c2 so here Gary
instead played Queen captures in c3 but
now comes the B captures in c4 and now
again a nipple created an incredibly
strong passed pawn and if he can get
something like Bishop to e6 in and that
to reinforce c4 and push d4 somehow then
then that's just it so Gary forces him
to break up his bone structure and here
what Gary's expecting is likely d4 and
after characters captures just go into
the send game Bishop captures here and
the material on the board is equal most
likely we just straight down into a draw
however nipple would not be nipple if he
played something like that he played d
captures on e4 instead he says I don't
mind ruining my pawn structure but I
will grab a pawn and here the problem is
if captures captures and captures now
okay it's similar but it's black who's
up upon its a double e pawn but still
only black can be better here and the
nepo is very happy to play this until
forever out of the force Aguirre into
submission
so after D captures on e4 we've worked
the h4 by Gary now adding more pressure
on the fourth-ranked he he wants to
recapture this with the rook but now
Bishop to e6 now in a po has a nicely
protected past C pawn whereas a Giri has
a passed a bond we have rookie actress
anny for winning back the pawn and only
now
Nero castles so what's what's happening
here Bishop captures on c4 this is this
is a move that a giri will will live to
regret unfortunately for him not another
unfortunately that he will live but that
he will have to regret it
Bishop captures on c4 it looks like such
a juicy pawn and the bishop is nicely
protected however it's really not
so once again feel free to pause the
video and try to try to refute this idea
by finding a great move for network
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on spotting that if if
if you're not pinned then it's actually
white who's pinned and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
King g7 now there's no pin for black but
there is a pin for white you cannot move
the bishop because your queen is
undefended on c3 so Queen to b3
immediately unpinning but now rook to b8
now netbook brings the rook into the
game and here it's it's impossible to
find a good square for the Queen that's
the problem for example if Queen d3 you
can just bring the bishop over here you
win you win material if you try
something like Queen to a4 then Bishop
to d7 is very strong and again if going
to d1 you can't keep an eye on
everything then Bishop here and although
you can keep an eye on the bishop let's
say you go rook to h4 but then rook the
b1 just wins the Queen so a lot of a lot
of problems for gearing so after
considering for quite some time
Giri decided to give up the Queen Bishop
characters on e6 we have rook out person
B 3 and now first before recapturing
first of course the giri gives a nip or
an opportunity to blunder the game with
rook g4 now of course if King h8 the
rook to G it is mate nip of course is
not interested in in such checkmate so
kink the f8 and only now bishop
character son b 3 so here bishop and
rook against the queen giri is hoping to
hold this to create some sort of a
fortress and of course nepo is here to
try and prove otherwise
and here this is basically where the
game starts up until now it was a Gary's
preparation against nip was incredible
resilience and you know he just he just
stood in there and came out on top but
is it enough well we'll just have to
wait and see Queen the c1
check by neppo we have came to g2 and
now Queen to c6 check just checking if
Gary will may be attached any scores
that he shouldn't we have king to g1 and
now h5
kicking away the rope we have rook to g8
width check King e7 Ruby g7 check King
d6 and
look the h7 going after the h5 bond and
here we have Queen to e3 defending and
now this is move 38 we need two more
moves to reach time control gear is down
to two minutes and nip was down to 18
minutes so and therefore a lot better
doing on time we have worked a trade
just wasting a move Giri really needs to
reach time control in the now efore
hoping to get that III moving and this
is move 40 he really needs a good one
and he finds it rook the d8 with check
King to e7 and now not moving the rook
but first Bishop to d1 and this is this
was crucial for give it to find not
allowing an effort to get pawn to e3
move so Queen to see three and now rook
to d5 d5 excellent square for the rook
because you want to play Bishop to d3
the guard the rook the pawn and
everything is nicely guarded so h4 by
Napo he knows that in order to win this
you just need to bust open the position
if he can get h4 in III in that's pretty
much game over so G captures on h4 by
giri and now you could try III in but
well we do go into this captures
captures with check King G tool it's a
queen e4 check Bishop to f3 to guard the
rook and now Queen captures on h4 and
well it's hard to say if you don't know
if this is a draw or if this is winning
you don't want to you don't want to rush
into it for example what if this rook
just goes here let's see well maybe not
to eat to because you shouldn't allow
this pawn here but I don't know somehow
finds his way let's say on e4 and you
bring the pawn to a4 is this a fortress
is it not a fortress it's hard to say
because well black always says f5 so you
will not be able to use these two
squares that you know now move around
the rook but he doesn't want to risk it
instead of III nip often Epiphanes f5 he
wants to just play f4 and then he three
and that's just game because if rook
captures here then Heep has a queen te
one with check picking up the bishop on
d1 the problem for Neto is that giri
actually played rook captures on f5 and
now we go into into a deep study Quinta
a one with check with Quinta g2
capture sandy won and now comes looked
and g5 so here's a here's a position for
you to analyze what would you play here
they're not gonna ask me to find the
move because this is really a deep study
and the Magnus crossing himself said
that this is an easy draw for white so
it's not it's not at all clear how to go
about this but if you want you can pause
the video and just think about the
position how would you go about it if
you've done that congratulations I I
commend you but we're gonna continue the
analysis now so here nappa tried Queen
to a-1 he wants to grab the pawn here
but I will show a force line that starts
with Queen to f3 check because it's just
well something you once you see it maybe
it sticks but it's hard to say king to
g1 now Queen to f4 you wanna get rid of
the age for pawn so rook the g3 Queen
captures on h4 and now a3 and it seems
like this is the dream for white because
you have a DA pawn protected and you can
just switch the ropes rookie three row
GT rookie three row g3 and you've
created a fortress but there is a
problem here
king d6 King to g2 King d5 you're gonna
go king g1 just repeat moves King to c4
King to g2 and now Queen f4 you're gonna
go king g1 just repeat moves all rook to
e3 doesn't really matter because here
it's a problem if you go King to g1 then
even Queen captures and g3 is a move F
captures and king d3 you're gonna go
here and 2d - and you are just much
faster in queening so you will not be
able to go for this so after Queen to f4
you cannot allow to move the King and
allow Queen captures you're gonna have
to go for rook to e3 but now King d4
again threatening to win the rook this
way and again your pawn is faster so
rook g3 but now Queen to d2 King to g1
and now comes Queen to death
Queen to d3 and again you cannot offer
the rook because well your opponent will
be just faster and this way you've
created a bridge for the King to the
cross the queen is shielding the King
from the rook this is a very very
exciting stuff King G - and now King c3
you're gonna go rook III King b3 you're
gonna
pick up the pawn king let's say King g3
or rook goes back doesn't really matter
but now King captures here and now it's
it's it's it's just winning there's not
much you can do here it's at some point
you're either either going to get here
pick up the rook
with the Queen and then Queen the pawn
or if just captures it and then this is
winning but yeah I really just wanted to
mention that because it's well it's hard
to imagine such things but okay never
went for Queen to a1 instead and now we
have looked to g4 a tricky move Gary
once for this capture to happen and then
after rook captures here then indeed it
will be incredibly hard to win this for
example King f6 you're just gonna go
look the e3 and now it is gonna be hard
without without the pawn so not hard
it's gonna be impossible to win this
because you don't have anything to play
with so after work the g4 Queen B 1
defends the pawn and now comes work to
g3 again here Gary decides to give up
the a 2 point but the point is after a 3
and the Queen to b3 we pretty much go
into the same line rook to g3 and Queen
to d5 not threatening III with check
king h2 and now a lot of different ways
you can play this Queen d1 King G - and
now King to d6 again you're gonna bring
your king and it's gonna be a similar
but a lot of things could happen for
example King gage - if you go King is -
Quinta f1 is incredibly strong and now
if ruby g2 defending the F pawn now you
bring the King in king e 5 let's say try
H 5 you're gonna go Queen e2 go after
the pawn h6 King to d4 with h7 now you
of course have to play h5 with check
pick up the pawn king here and now even
III have captures King captures on e3
and now without the f1 for white it will
be of course winning let's say check
King f4 ruby g2 and Queen captures on h7
and now this is a unknown winning
endgame for black so that's why Gary
decided that it was maybe best to waste
a move and give up the pawn immediately
as it's not really crucial to him
achieving some sort of a fortress so
rogue g2 and the now comes Queen
captures on a2 by nipple
lukkage three now Gary will just write a
wiggle with the rook Queen to d5
threatening III with check so came to f1
and now Queen to d1 with chair King to
g2 and now comes Queen to g4 with check
rook to g3 and now Queen to h5 problem
is everyone was saying that Queen
captures on h4 is a draw for Gary
because if King captures Queen captures
on h4 then King f2 King f1 and everyone
said that if King reaches a 1 or e to
that this is a known raw but there is a
problem to this because if Queen to h1
check then you have to go to e2 and now
King e6 and now again you're gonna see
something really really incredible look
III how are you supposed to it's
impossible to create a bridge now
because both of the king and the rook
guard the d3 square but you don't need
the bridge here King d5 you're gonna go
rule g3 now King d4 you're gonna go rook
III now Queen h5 now you try and kick
away the king from the d3 square so it's
a king e1 you're gonna go Queen to a5
with Chuck
kingi - now comes Queen b5 with Jeff
King e1 Queen to be one with check again
King e2 now Queen c2 with check King to
e1 and now Queen to see one with check
and here's the here's the beauty
kingi - and now Queen captures on e3
pawn captures and this is winning for
black king c3 and that's it this is a of
course no one no one can know such
things but once once you see it then
it's just amazing he won of course King
D 3 you gained opposition captures
captures and of course it's winning
so after rook the g3 nipa could have
gone through characters on h4 but
instead he went Queen to h5 he wants to
create a two-prong and he wants the he
will try and win d h4 pawn with his king
so with after this we have looked a
three by gearing and now he starts with
Quinta d5 again threatening discovery
King g1 and now King f6 we have looked
to g3 cutting the King off but now Queen
d1 check King to g2 and now King to f5
we have looked a GFI with check King a4
and wrote back to g3 and now Queen d5
against
this nasty discovery came to f1 and now
Queen to d2 forcing the king to move yet
again kink the g2 ended now Queen d1 and
now you have to make a move either you
start with h5 and then the Queen just
picks it up or you can try something
else so look the e3 was played
but now the King finally crosses the G
file King f5 we have rook to g3 now King
f6 and now rook to h3 now preparing to
pull the pawn but now King g6 the King
could have crossed the G file earlier
but it doesn't really matter never has
all the time in the world to try
anything
rook the g3 check King to h5 and now
rook to h3 here URI makes it a bit
easier he played rook to h3 instead of
rook to e3 point is that if captures
then captures we again reach this drawn
endgame King g5 rookie 15 g f6 and now
rook to e3 will be enough for a draw
without the black pawn so rook to e3
would have been more resilient and again
a nipple would have to find that whole
idea that that it should be it will be
winning even with the H pawn to just
shave the king over here and play this
Queen to d3 incredibly strong move and
then of course the rook will not capture
it but then the point is that once the
Queen reaches the three you create a
bridge here you bring the King over to
e1 and then you have Queen e2 to F 1
with check and you pick up the f2 pawn
that's that's the winning idea but Geary
makes it easier with rook to h3 and now
again a wasting move Queen b1 you guard
the the pawn and force the rook to move
rook the rook to e3 and only now King
characters on h4 so really really
incredible stuff worked the g3 but now
king h5 but at this point both Geary and
never knew that now it's completely
winning because now never knows that
bringing the this King here and the
Queen to d2 remove is what what needs to
happen so rook h3 king g4 we worked the
g3 King to f4 and now rook to e3 we have
Queen to d1 I just not allowing the King
any moves
controlling more squares preparing Queen
to d3 with rook to a3 and now
kingi 5 you need to bring the king to d4
we have rook to g3 King to d4 with rook
to e3 and finally and move 73 Jana pony
she played Queen to d3 and it was in
this position that uh nigiri resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here like I said if the queen is
captured of course the the deep one is
much faster than the F pawn obviously
but if it's not it's the the idea we've
already discussed if rook g3 you're just
gonna play King's c3 trying to wheel
your way in with the king and here you
don't really have any moves it the king
is just going all the way that he wanted
an Queen f1 followed by captures here or
if you play something again just
characters characters and king to b3 is
a winning king and pony endgame for
black king f2 king D - you gain a
position of course the white king cannot
touch f3 so you have to move captures
and now of course it's completely
winning king b3 you just push the pawn
let's say go here and now pawn here this
game is so complicated my computer seems
to be lagging it's really really
incredible but yeah a king of - of
course you go to d2 and then you Queen
the pawn and win the game but they are
really incredible stuff everything about
this game was just awesome
the opening givers preparation and you
know a nipple just riding out the storm
it was it was really incredible and then
therefore actually winning this with
black in round one of the 20/20
candidates tournament we are definitely
off to a great start and if you don't
know there were some other of surprises
in round 1 so we're gonna cover all of
them before we actually show the
standings so now that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I'm sure Geary
didn't then he's gonna really have to
collect himself before going into round
around to do III would like to thank
Frank combs in jeremy everett for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here I'm
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament and whatever we
can squeeze in maybe on rest days
regarding the morphe saga and your
suggestions but we'll see how it goes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day